The Truth About Clothes Moths
The common “clothes moth”, “clothing
moth” or to give its street name, Tineola
bisselliella, doesn’t actually eat clothes.
In fact, clothing moths don’t even possess
the ability to eat- they don’t have a mouth.
Once they become a moth, rather than waste
their time eating, they simply mate, the female
lays her eggs, and then they die at some point.
Meaning the most damage to your clothes you
could realistically expect from an adult clothing
moth is a stain if you go postal on one with
a newspaper.
So how did these moths get associated with
eating clothes?
It’s the moth babies you need to be wary
of, which are able to get proteins they need
from keratin- in other words, virtually any
organic fibre derived from an animal.
And boy do those things have an appetite.
The full list of things clothes moth larvae
can eat is pretty insane- basically they can
eat and survive on virtually any natural fibre.
They’ve been known to eat wool, cashmere,
silk, cotton, linen, fur, feathers, hair,
lint, carpets, the bristles of brushes, pet
fur and even dust.
On top of this, the larvae will also, if no
food is present, cut, not eat through non-natural
fibres like polyester to reach your ever dwindling
supply of wool underwear.
The fibres the larva eats eventually also
ends up becoming a part of the cocoon it spins
for itself so it can become a moth and stop
having to eat sweaty boxer shorts and get
down to the much more fun act of mating.
If their voracious appetite isn’t bad enough,
the larvae are also notably hardy and difficult
to kill through indirect means.
For example, the larvae and eggs of a clothes
moth can easily survive temperature extremes
as high as 50 degrees Celsius (122 degrees
F) and as low as -8 degrees C (17.6 degrees
F) for short periods.
As such, it’s recommended that you expose
them to such extremes for at least a half
an hour to really make sure they’re all
dead.
As explained above, larvae will straight up
chew through whatever they need to in order
to get to their food, which for the eagle
eyed ones amongst you probably stood out as
a little odd.
If the adult moth sensed a wool sweater in
a wardrobe, why would it lay its eggs on a
spandrels Borat mankini?
Well this is because the larvae and moths
are actually drawn to the moisture in certain
clothes because the larvae must get the moisture
they need through their food.
This is also the reason dry cleaning your
clothes is an effective moth deterrent.
You might have guessed from this that clothing
moths and their larvae are also attracted
to dirty clothes, in particular ones dirtied
by sweat, as sweat contains not only moisture
but salt and other minerals the larvae needs
to survive.
But, bottom line, the moths themselves aren’t
doing the damage, it is their children, which
is also typically true for humans…